♪
>> Brian: NEW REPORTS REVEAL THE
U.S. SENT PRIVATE MESSAGES TO
RUSSIA WARNING AGAINST USING
NUCLEAR WEAPONS AS THEY
THREATENED BECAUSE THEY ARE
LOSING THIS WAR IN UKRAINE IT
SEEMS THIS AS RUSSIAN MEN ARE
FLEEING THE COUNTRY RAPIDLY TO
AVOID VLADIMIR PUTIN'S MILITARY
DRAFT.
HERE TO REACT GENERAL JACK KEANE
RETIRED FOUR STAR GENERAL FOX
NEWS STRATEGIC ANALYST.
GENERAL, THEY ARE PREVENTING 18
TO 34-YEAR-OLDS FROM BUYING ONE
WAY TICKETS OUT OF THE COUNTRY.
THE LINE TO KAZAKHSTAN AND
MONGOLIA IS THROUGH THE ROOF AND
JUST ABOUT 6,000 PEOPLE LEFT
INTO FINLAND YESTERDAY TRYING TO
GET OUT OF THAT COUNTRY.
AND WE ARE WATCHING RIOTS TAKE
PLACE.
HOW SIGNIFICANT IS THIS?
>> OH, I THINK IT'S VERY SELLING
SIGNIFICANT.
PUTIN WAS FORCED INTO THIS.
NOT SOMETHING HE REALLY WANTED
TO DO OBVIOUSLY.
HE HAS PEOPLE, HIS ULTRA
NATIONALISTS THAT ARE REALLY
CRITICIZING TO HIM FOR THE
CONDUCT OF THE WAR.
THEY WANTED FULL MOBILIZATION TO
BE ABLE TO PUT THE UKRAINIANS TO
BED ONCE AND FOR ALL.
>> HE KNOWS THAT WOULD BE AN
ABSOLUTE POLITICAL DISASTER FOR
HIM BECAUSE MANY OF THE
INFLUENTIAL PEOPLE IN RUSSIA'S
CHILDREN WOULD BE DRAFTED INTO
THE WAR.
I MEAN, WHY ARE PEOPLE RUNNING
FROM THIS WAR?
IF RUSSIA WAS REALLY BEING
THREATENED BY ANOTHER COUNTRY,
AND THEIR SURVIVAL WAS AT STAKE,
WE KNOW THE HISTORY OF THE
RUSSIAN PEOPLE.
THEY WOULD FIGHT.
AND THEY WOULD STAND UP FOR
THEIR COUNTRY.
BUFF PEOPLE ARE RUNNING FROM
THIS BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE A
STAKE IN IT.
AND AS FAR AS THEY ARE
CONCERNED.
SEVEN MONTHS AGO THIS WAS IN A
FAR AWAY PLACE FROM WHERE THEY
ARE LIVING AND THEY WERE NOT
INVOLVED.
AND NOW PUTIN HAS GOT THEM
INVOLVED IN THIS.
SO I THINK IT'S LIKELY THIS WILL
BLOW BACK ON THEM.
AND EVEN IF HE IS ABLE TO
ASSEMBLE HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF TROOPS, HERE'S WHAT IS GOING
TO SHOW UP.
PEOPLE WHO ARE PHYSICALLY UNFIT.
PEOPLE ARE MEDICALLY UNFIT.
AND OBVIOUSLY PEOPLE WHO ARE
PSYCHOLOGICALLY AND EMOTIONALLY
NOT READY TO FIGHT WHAT ARE THEY
GOING TO JOIN?
JOIN A UNIT ON THE BATTLE FIELD
POORLY LED, POORLY TRAINED AND
NOT BEEN SUCCESSFUL AT
CONDUCTING THE OPERATIONS THAT
THEY ARE PURSUING.
SO, YES.
PUTIN HAS GOT A PROBLEM HERE.
IS HE LOSING THE WAR NOW.
DOESN'T MEAN HE WILL EVENTUALLY
LOSE IT.
BUT HE CERTAINLY IS ON HIS WAY
TO THAT.
STEVE.
>> Brian: UNDERSTAND HE IS I
GOING TO TRY DO PHONY ANNEXES IN
A FEW DAYS.
THIS IS THE VOTE.
AREAS OF THE DONBAS ARE GOING TO
BE PART OF RUSSIA.
THAT MEANS WE HAVE TO DEFEND OUR
LAND.
WHAT'S BEHIND THIS?
, WELL, IT'S A POLITICAL
STATEMENT TO SHOW SOME DEGREE OF
SUCCESS POOR THAN ANYTHING ELSE
THAT'S WHAT THIS IS HE KNOWS
FULL WELL THAT EVEN IN THE
DONBAS REGION THEY DON'T
DEPLETELY HAVE CONTROL OF THAT
TERRITORY.
NONE OF THESE TERRITORIES, THE
FOUR OF THEM THAT HE IS
CLAIMING, DO THEY HAVE COMPLETE
CONTROL OF.
SO, THIS IS NOT A MILITARY
EFFORT IS HE TAKING HERE.
THIS IS A POLITICAL EFFORT AND
IT'S TRYING TO DEMONSTRATE SOME
DEGREE OF SUCCESS TO HIS
DOMESTIC AUDIENCE MORE THAN
ANYTHING ELSE.
IT'S COMPLETELY HOLT LOW ON THE
SURFACE OF IT.
AND IN TERMS OF ATTACKING IT,
LISTEN, UKRAINIANS HAVE WITHIN
ATTACKING CRIMEA WHICH ALREADY
IS ANNEXED BY RUSSIA AND IN
THEORY A PART OF RUSSIA.
AND RUSSIA HAS NOT RESPONDED IN
KIND AS A MATTER OF FACT, THERE
HAS BEEN FLEEING GOING ON BY THE
PEOPLE IN THAT PART OF THE
COUNTRY WHERE THE UKRAINIANS
HAVE BEEN SUCCESSFUL IN
CONDUCTING AN OPERATIONS IN
CRIMEA.
>> Brian: FRIENDLY NEWS OUTLETS
ARE BEGINNING TO CRITICIZE THE
WAR AND VLADIMIR PUTIN THE
PROTESTS ARE GETTING BIGGER THIS
WHOLE THING IS COMING APART FOR
THAT BRUTAL DICTATOR OUR MODERN
DAY STALIN/HITLER.
GENERAL JACK KEANE, THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
>> YEAH.
GREAT TALKING TO YOU, BRIAN.
HAVE A WONDERFUL WEEKEND YOU AND
THE TEAM.
AINS.
>> Brian: ABSOLUTELY.
THE GENERAL NEVER STOPS
MONITORING THE SITUATION